The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this is a really,
really, really, really
stunning fact in a sense of we
talk about lots of forms of
inequality and unfairness
in the world.
But here's a fact that's
really quite,
quite, quite striking.
You start from the basic,
just the fact.
It's the fact that if you look
at the ratio of men and women
in the population, most
countries in the world have
many more women than men.
This is mostly because
women are just better
designed, it turns out.
When men get to the age of about
60, various bad things
happen to them.
In particular, their arteries
seem to harden.
And lots of them die
from various
cardiovascular diseases.
So as a result, most countries
have many more women than men.
So the ratios up there,
Europe has 1.05.
Sub-Saharan Africa has 1.02.
All of Latin America
is above 1.
The US is about 1.
And while it doesn't look like a
lot, 4%, we're talking about
4% of 3 billion.
So that's a fair number
of extra women
we're talking about.
The world has many more women
than men overall.
But the one place where that's
not true is in this belt which
goes from basically North
Africa to Korea.
That's that one belt in the
world pretty much all the way.
You can draw a belt starting
somewhere in Morocco and keep
going east, about at
that latitude.
And then go a bit north into
China, and you'll find that
that's where they are about
4% or less women than men.
These numbers are not
necessarily the worst numbers
you're going to see.
So I'll show you some more
striking numbers in a minute.
I mean, just the fact that
there's 6% less women than men
is striking, given that that
doesn't look like the
biological model.
So Amartya Sen, who was a Nobel
Prize winner at Harvard
did this calculation, basically
very simple
calculation.
He said, look, Sub-Saharan
Africa is the
poorest part of the world.
So if there is some maybe
institutional reason why women
die, so there might be reasons
why women die that have to do
with poverty.
What's an example of a reason,
which would hurt women more
than men, reason why
poverty would hurt
women more than men?
AUDIENCE: During childbirth.
PROFESSOR: Childbirth, the
obvious one is childbirth.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And then compounding
upon that, if women in poor
situations have less access to
contraceptives and have more
children, which increases
the lack [INAUDIBLE].
There will be complications
for [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So everything to do
with childbirth is reason why
you might think that in poor
countries, women will have a
disadvantage.
You do see evidence of
the disadvantage.
Sub-Saharan Africa has less
women than Europe.
So you do see an example
of that disadvantage.
It's about 2 percentage points
or 3 percentage points less
women than Europe.
If you think of Sub-Saharan
Africa as the part of the
world which has the highest
maternal mortality rates.
It's the part of the world
which has the highest
fertility rates.
Both to your point and your
point, if you take the part of
the world where women are most
likely to die in childbirth,
and the place where women have
the most children, both of
those are highest in
Sub-Saharan Africa.
So you could think of this
as being a reasonable
approximation of the worst
case scenario.
Take the worst case scenario
and then go to China.
So that's the exercise.
Let's take the worst
case scenario.
Now go to China and ask, if
we applied the Sub-Saharan
African ratio to the Chinese
population, how many more
women would they have had?
The answer is they would have
had 44 million more women.
So 44 million more women
are missing.
And you keep doing that, and
same order of magnitude in
India, and then smaller
countries, so smaller numbers,
but it all adds up toward
100 million.
So you get about 100 million
missing women in the world by
doing this simple exercise.
And that's sort of prima
facie evidence.
As we'll see, you have to think
harder about exactly
what this evidence means.
This is prima facie evidence
of something
very bizarre happening.
We'll see what's
going on here.
But there's something very
troubling about this fact.
Because it seems like somehow
populations are managing to
get rid of women, quote unquote,
"losing women"
through mechanisms which are
not the normal biological
mechanisms.
So that's the missing women.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this order for
killing women in China, are
they missing in rural China?
Or is it just all
around China?
PROFESSOR: I'll show
you in a minute.
I'll show you all kinds of facts
about China, in fact.
So before I come to that,
there's just some hypotheses
you might have.
One is, is development
the answer?
Maybe there's some reason why
just being undeveloped for
reasons we don't understand
translates into less women.
Maybe we have a theory that
maybe it's the case that
people are more traditional,
something.
Now what makes this fact much
more worrying is that
development is not making
this fact go away.
That's sort of at least
within modern history.
We don't know what happened
100 years ago.
But right now, development is
not making this fact go away.
If you look at the sex ratio in
India, it's not changing.
It's in fact pretty
much steady.
I'll show you numbers
in a minute.
If you look at the sex ratio
in China, it's falling.
It's less and less women
every year in China.
And if you look at the richest
parts of China versus the
poorest part to your question,
you see a negative
correlation.
The riches parts of China
are the ones which
have the least women.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we know anything
about missing men?
Maybe there's some component
where there's just a general
[INAUDIBLE] for children in
some parts of the world.
And the number of children
in total are missing,
not just the girls.
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
I think that's what people do
when they say, the infant
mortality rate is too
high or something.
And I think that that's
also a concern.
It's not that there
aren't other
concerns because of this.
A lot of people would say that
you shouldn't just look at GDP
to measure welfare.
Emphasize infant mortality
rates.
Infant mortality rates is
exactly the question you're
asking, missing boys
and girls.
That number is very high
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
Sub-Saharan Africa has the
highest infant mortality rate
in the world by far.
China has now infant mortality
rates which are approaching
that in the US.
So infant morality rates by
itself, by now it's not a huge
problem in China.
China is down to the range
where it's very, very
close to the US.
I think it has infant mortality
rates of like 25 our
of 1,000, 1,000 live births.
US has 18 or 14 or something.
It's really in the range, where
Sub-Saharan Africa,
Sierra Leone has 140.
So if you want to see where
infant mortality is a problem,
that's not where missing
women is a problem.
These are different problems.
It's not to say you're
not right.
That's another problem.
But it's a different one.
So this is sort of just
to show you that fact.
So what I showed you so far
was the levels, how
many women per men.
This is, in 2005, what's
the future.
Future's much more scary
than the present.
The present is what--
there was like 95 girls
per 100 boys.
So that's about 105 boys
per 100 girls.
That's the current.
The future, look at the number
for Eastern Asia.
That number is 120 boys
for 100 girls.
It's a completely different
order of magnitude.
Think of the future.
These are the kids who are
being born under five.
So at point, if this is what
stays steady, we are going to
see numbers more like
120 than 105.
Right now there are 105 boys
to 100 girls in China.
And that number is going to go
up to closer to 120 as this
cohort ages.
So that's just backing up the
first claim I made, which is
it's not getting better.
If you look at the number
for India, it's 108.
108 is bigger than the
current ratio of
men to women in India.
So current ratio is about
106, and that's 108.
So all of these countries,
which are getting richer,
their ratio is getting worse.
Do you see what this is, how it
this is different from the
one I showed you before?
This is the ratio among
under fives.
So these are the future of the
population, whereas I showed
you the present of
the population.
Future's worse, not better.
Korea has the same kind of
numbers, which are worse.
Interestingly, Afghanistan and
Nepal, which are relatively
poor countries, are not getting
rich very fast,
actually you don't see
much of a change.
They're about where they were.
Under five is about what they
are in the adult population.
So that suggests that they
aren't getting worse.
It's the richer countries
that are getting
richer are getting worse.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't you
expect this number to be
higher than the overall
population because women are
more likely to live longer
and more [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
absolutely true.
So 121 go to 120.
120 is going to go to 115.
That's about the difference.
So 120 is going to
do 115 of 14.
But 114 is a lot
worse than 106.
All of the trends are bad.
Just to understand, this
is a big problem.
And it's not one that's getting
solved on its own as
far as I can tell.
So here's another way
to look at it.
So this is India and China.
Give yourself a few minutes
to look at this.
So the darkest areas are
the worst areas.
Does anybody know which are
the richer areas of China?
AUDIENCE: The black areas?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's pretty
much exactly the same.
I think Shanghai is that gray
area right there, which is
actually doing surprisingly
well.
The really poor areas of China
are those very light
areas in the west.
That's the Gobi Desert, the
Taklamakan Desert, the Chinkiang.
All the areas with large Muslim
populations are in the east.
These are the poorest parts of
China, and they're the ones
which are doing by
far the best.
The areas that are being really
badly are the most
prosperous.
The dark areas in the southeast,
that's like
Guangdong, and Guangzhou, and
all these really fast-growing,
wealthy provinces of China,
that's the southeast.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I'm not really sure
exactly how [INAUDIBLE],
but the fact that there is
[INAUDIBLE] in the number of
kids that couples can have.
You know, people might be
deciding on purpose to have
boys because they want boys
for whatever reason.
And maybe the people who make
those decision are people to
have more money, because to have
abortions is expensive.
PROFESSOR: I think that has
a lot to do with it.
We'll come back to it.
You're perfectly right that a
lot of this ease has something
to do with people's active
choices also.
I'll come back to that
in a little.
As China gets even richer,
because this is the trend, and
it's a worrying trend,
let's say.
Now look at India.
Again, do you know what those
relatively pale areas are?
AUDIENCE: South India?
PROFESSOR: The South India,
which is relatively prosperous
and well-educated, and East
India which is the poorest and
the most backward
part of India.
Richest state in India, large
state in India, is
Maharashtra, which is kind
of the striped state.
Let's see, on the west coast,
if you go from the south on
the west coast, the first
striped one, that's
Maharashtra.
That's the richest.
The second richest large state
is Punjab And Punjab is that
piece of black that's
right in the north.
So that's literally the second
richest, and still recently
the richest state in India,
is that area in black.
So again, the same pattern--
rich states have worse outcomes,
not better outcomes.
And there's no evidence of a
positive correlation between
income and the gender ratio.
AUDIENCE: Is Punjab the only
state in India that has a
different religion than the
rest of the others?
Or would that be a reason?
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
What that is is there's really
two states there.
There is Punjab and Haryana.
They used to be both
a part of Punjab.
Now they've been split into
two states for some years.
But one of those states
is Sheik majority.
Sheik is a particular
other religion.
The other is Hindu majority.
There's no difference.
Actually, Haryana's slightly
worse that Punjab.
Delhi City is one of the worst
places, actually, in India.
So that's one of the absolutely
riches places.
So basically no evidence of a
positive correlation between
income and the gender ratio--
gender ratio, if anything, gets
worse as you get richer,
for reasons that may very
be close to what you're
suggesting.
But it's clear that you get this
rather dismal pattern.
Here's something else, another
fact about sort of China.
And it's sort of a very long
term view of China.
This starts in 1920.
And you can see that basically
from the 1920s the excess sex
ratio, which is in the five-year
birth cohort.
So people who were born in that
year, what's the fraction
of boys versus girls?
So it used to be about 7%
more boys than girls.
Then it went up to about 16%
during the years when there's
a lot of political
instability.
So if you think of those years
as Japanese invasion, before
that and after that, in a sense,
China is in civil war.
What are called the warlords
are fighting each other
through China.
So during wars, you see this
ratio going way up.
Then it comes in down, down,
down, down, down, down, down,
down, till about 1976
or something.
Now right around 1976 something
else happens.
China introduces what's called
the one child policy.
The one child policy is one
where at least in the richer
areas, where it was the only
place it was enforced,
families were allowed to have
only one child at most.
Then that policy gets
implemented in the mid '70s.
And you see what's
happened since.
What's striking is it doesn't
just go up and stay up.
It keeps going up.
So there's something else going
on on top of the fact
that the one child policy
gets instituted.
In fact, over time, the one
child policy has been relaxed.
And this reflects some
of the tests of
the population clearly.
Families which had one daughter
in some areas were
allowed to have a son or have a
second child more recently.
So there's some attempt to relax
the policy in exactly
the direction that suggests
that there's a
preference for boys.
But with all that, the
trend has been up.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Do you know what's
happened to those policies?
Were they implemented,
[INAUDIBLE] relaxation?
PROFESSOR: A bunch to the
relaxations happen.
You see they're flattening
in about 1982.
That's the first relaxation.
So you do see a flattening,
but the trend is bad.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Even if it's being
relaxed, just being relaxed,
if the first kid that you have
is a girl, and then in that
case, you might then
try to have a boy?
But if they had the boy right
away, maybe they'd just stop
having kids.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Actually, let's take it.
So could this be generated
by a stopping rule?
So imagine that families have a
stopping rule which says, we
will stop when we have
the first boy.
This is their stopping rule.
This is a plausible
stopping rule.
My mother has one brother
and three sisters.
The brother's the youngest.
So that's not an implausible
stopping rule.
My mother's only brother has
three daughters and once son.
The son is the youngest.
It's not an implausible
stopping rule.
However, imagine we had
this stopping rule.
But in any but, the probability
of boy and girl
would equal.
What would be the population
sex ratio?
AUDIENCE: Still the same.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
boys, right?
No, you'd have more women.
AUDIENCE: No, it's half.
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: If you keep having
children when you have women,
then you stop as soon as you
have one boy, you'd have more
women, or you would
expect more women.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
You stop immediately.
You stop immediately if
you have one son.
[INAUDIBLE].
There might be a family where
there are more girls
[INAUDIBLE].
But most families
will stop there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So do you think
they'll be more [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I think it pretty
much evens out.
AUDIENCE: I think there will be
more boys, because if you
have a boy, you just stop.
So then that family
just has a boy.
And if you have a girl and then
you try again, if you
have a boy, then right now you
have one family with one boy
and another family with
a girl and a boy.
But there's still more
boys than girls.
So whenever you get to
a boy, you stop.
PROFESSOR: You want to
come back to that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and so if we
just do an expected values,
and you get half.
Half the cases you'll
have one boy.
What are the cases
of girl and boy?
PROFESSOR: You're
exactly right.
The answer is it doesn't
change anything.
And it's very simple to see.
The reason why it
doesn't change
anything is very simple.
Which is that every but has a
50% chance of having a boy.
So just take the number buts.
Forget about families.
There's a certain
number of buts.
Let's say 50 million buts.
25 million of those
buts will be boys.
And 25 million of those
buts with be girls.
It doesn't matter which
family it happens.
Every but is a separate,
independent event and has a
50% chance of being a boy.
So paradoxical as it sounds,
stopping girls don't change
the sex ratio.
They change the distribution.
Now here's what might be
going on, which is more
complication.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But again, but the
relaxation is now there.
Like, it's completely relaxed.
So then you can have it.
So it won't be true if you can
have as many kids as possible.
This is going to make a
difference, though, if you
have to stall--
PROFESSOR: As long as you don't
determine the sex of the
child directly, it
doesn't matter.
Every but is an independent
event with a 50% chance of
being a boy.
So take the number of bus,
multiply it by 50%, you're
going to get the number.
So it makes no difference.
Now let's think of one more
step in the [INAUDIBLE].
Which families would a lot
of girls grow up in?
Would they have more children
or less children?
Would girls grow up on average
in a family with more children
or less children?
AUDIENCE: More children.
PROFESSOR: More children.
So if you think that families
that have more children have
less resources, then you have
a stopping rule, then girls
would be growing up in families
with more children,
and therefore less resources.
And therefore, a stopping rule
can have an effect on child
outcomes, because it leads to
girls all living in large
families and boys all living
in small families.
So boys get all the attention,
the parent, the resources.
The seven girls and one boy
in the girl families, and
therefore the girls end up with
getting less resources.
So that's one possible reason
why you might get this
outcome, because it has
something to do with the
stopping rule, but
not directly.
It has to do with the stopping
rule then generates an
allocation of girls
across families.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So that's also true.
But If you think of about even
with the relaxation, imagine a
family in a rich area where
everything's more expensive.
Let's say even if it was a
little more relaxed, they
still limit themselves to say,
OK, we're going to have a
maximum of two kids.
So let's say, yeah, maybe the
first kid that they have is a
girl, but then they say, the
probability of having a girl
for the next one, maybe it's not
really 50%, because they
say, well, we're only going to
have this kid if it's a boy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
what you're saying
is completely right.
The only way you get away from
50-50 is by deliberately or at
least doing something to the
girl that makes her not live.
That's the only way
you get there.
If the girls who are born
live, then you can't
get away from this.
It doesn't matter what your
stopping rule is.
Even if the government makes
complicated policies, the
policies don't change that.
Every but is either
a boy or girl.
So here's the last fact I wanted
you to see, which is
that if you look at these sex
ratios in India, they're
getting worse.
They got worse for a while, now
they have stabilized at a
low number.
So in 1900, there were 972 girls
for boys, men for women,
women for men.
Now there are 933.
In India, you don't see a trend
after 1971 or 1981.
But the historical trend
is very negative.
So that brings us to sort
of the question.
Before we get to policy, in
a sense we need to know
what's going on.
What's going on-- there are
two possible answers.
One is kind of tradition, and
the other is economics.
So one is there's a set of
traditions which make bad
things happen.
But people are not willing
them to happen.
The other is that people are
actually making choices to
make these things happen.
So what we're going to spend
some time doing is trying to
distinguish between
these two views.
Is it tradition?
Is it economics?
So you could imagine just
traditionally there's a theory
which says that girls
need less food.
That's false.
But you believe it.
And you don't actually
actively do anything
to make them die.
You have wrong beliefs.
You think girls need less food,
because adult women are
smaller than adult men.
And so you feed your
girls less.
This is not an attempt to kill
them, it's just a tradition.
But then that could feed back
and have a consequence.
Problem is how do
you test this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you actually look
at fertility rates, so if the
number of people that are born
are essentially all 50-50, but
then within five years you would
see a clear difference.
So maybe at some point
that's happening.
But even if in turns of birth
rate, if there's a difference,
then it's something else.
PROFESSOR: So one answer to this
question is if these guys
are not getting born, then
obviously something
else is going on.
Now mostly still about five
years, not five, 15 years ago,
you don't see a big trend
in birthrates.
Now you actually see a trend
in birthrates as well,
reported butts they're more
and more reported boys
relative to girls.
But over 15 years ago,
you don't see that.
What you did see was more
different mortality rates for
boys and girls.
So imagine that you wanted
to test this view.
Well the problem is how
do you test it?
You don't actually observe who
eats what in a family.
So it's hard to imagine you
going and figuring out oh,
they're not feeding
their daughter.
They're feeding their son.
That's just too difficult to do,
because everybody eats out
of the same cooked food.
And so it's going to be
very hard to find.
Somebody had a very good
idea of how to do it.
We just looked at specialized
adult goods, like cigarettes.
Your daughter, a five-year-old
daughter, doesn't smoke a
cigarette, nor does your
five-year-old son.
So when a son is born, if
there's an effect on how much
smoking you do, it has nothing
to do with the children, the
children smoking.
So children are not going to be
a direct source of demand.
So why is that good?
Because then you can look at
what happens to smoking when
the family gets a
boy or a girl.
And if girls are fed less,
what would you expect?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
They would smoke more cigarettes
because they have a
larger share of their budget
to spend on cigarettes,
because they'll give
less to the girl.
PROFESSOR: Right, smoking
goes down by less.
So the basic observation you
should see is when a child is
born, adult income goes down,
because adults have less money
to spend on themselves,
because they
will feed the child.
But if they feed the girl less
than the boy, then you'd see
that when a boy is born, they'll
really cut back on
cigarettes.
But when a girl is born,
they'll cut back less.
Because they are feeding
the girl less.
We have a pretty precise
measurement of demand for
adult goods.
So we can use that.
We don't know who smokes.
But we know that the kids are
not doing the smoking.
So therefore, we can by
observing what happens to a
family when the child is born.
We can back out whether or not
there is a difference in the
way you feed boys or girls.
Is that clear why that's better
than trying to measure?
It's very hard to measure
who eats what.
But clearly the kids don't
smoke cigarettes.
And they don't drink alcohol.
So if you look at alcohol, and
cigarettes, and a few other
things that are essentially
adult goods, we should be able
to back out what's happening
when the child is born.
Somebody did that.
So take beverages.
Beverages doesn't
include milk.
So it's soda, and tea, and
all of those things.
This table is horrible, but this
paper was published in a
obscure journal many
years ago.
This is just a scan of that.
There's nothing else
I could find.
There's no electronic
version, et cetera.
What you're looking for is the
effect of a boy versus a girl,
so number of males between
zero and four, versus the
number of females between zero
and four, and the effect of
that on the consumption
of beverages.
And the answer is it has no
effect, that what's in the
bracket is the tea statistic.
The tea statistic is zero.
Both the numbers are zero.
And that's basically
what you find.
You see what you'd expect, which
is that, for example,
when a child is born,
you're just poorer.
So you buy less rice,
less wheat.
But there's no difference
between girls and boys.
Boys and girls have the same
effect, if anything, on both.
Basically there's no evidence
that when boy child is born,
families cut back more than
when a girl child is born.
We don't find any evidence.
And this will be looked
in many countries.
So another tradition story
is the following.
Imagine that tradition is when
the child gets sick, do I take
it to the hospital?
And with the boy, the tradition
is I always take it
to the hospital.
With a girl, I just give her
some water and generally sing
songs to her, but I don't take
her to the hospital,
something like that.
Do we see any evidence
of this?
So this is hard to study,
because we don't actually
observe that many episodes of
life-threatening diseases.
But there's a nice fact that
Elaina Rose identified, which
is the following.
Over time, different parts
of India have droughts at
different points of time.
So some areas have
droughts in 2006.
Some have droughts in 2004.
Some have droughts in 1996.
So a drought is a time
of economic stress.
What's a drought?
Why is it economic stress?
AUDIENCE: Lower end qualities
to low crop yield.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, basically
you can't grow anything.
It's too dry.
So when the rains fail,
crops fail.
Families have no money.
Well, how are they dealing with
this particular emergency?
And there she finds some
evidence that relative to
non-drought years, in drought
years, girls die more.
So that suggests that
emergencies might be
a part of the story.
In emergencies, girls are
not treated as well.
So I gave one example,
which is not
taking her to the hospital.
The other one might be, when I
don't have money, I don't buy
food for her.
So some tradition of that
kind might explain it.
Problem is that droughts are
not frequent enough.
And remember the trends.
The trends are all bad.
They're all getting worse.
India and China are
getting richer.
The dependence on agriculture
in general, these kinds of
extreme events, is
just going down.
Droughts don't matter as
much in India now.
30 years ago, agriculture
was 50% of GDP.
Now it's 25% of GDP.
So basically, droughts matter
less to people.
And since droughts matter less
to people, you would imagine
the trend being favorable
rather than against.
Think of China.
Most people are now
in industry.
They're also richer.
And as you get richer, and you
would imagine that emergencies
are less serious.
Because you always
have some money.
You're no longer at the
margin of starvation.
So the problem with this story
is that it's just inconsistent
with the fact the things are
getting worse over time.
You would think that under this
story things would be
getting better, because it's
an emergency story.
And as countries get richer and
less exposed to risk, you
would see less and less
of this, rather
than more and more.
So that's why this can't be
the whole explanation.
It could be a piece of it.
So going back to our distinction
between kind of
the tradition-based stories and
the more economic stories,
here is an economic fact,
which is striking.
So in other words, what I mean
by an economic story is that
tradition-based stories say that
there's some rule people
use, fixed rule.
They have not decided
on this rule.
This is given to them.
And that rule somehow, under
some circumstances, has bad
outcome for girls.
So when the girl is
sick, you don't
take her to the hospital.
That's a rule.
We're now asking a question,
when the economic incentives
to treat girls better changes,
do you treat them better?
That suggests that you don't
have a fixed rule.
You're actually behaving in a
rational way, quote unquote
"rational way." You're actually
planning to have bad
things happen to girls.
So do you see what the
distinction is between
tradition-based stories
and economic stories?
Economic stories are ones which
essentially say that we
are making active choices which
have consequences for
girls, rather than this is a
rule we use and sometimes bad
things happen, because we
use a particular rule.
Here is a nice example.
So in China, after 1979,
agriculture is liberalized,
meaning people are allowed to
keep the money from going
their crops.
This is the start of China's
economic miracle.
It's called the family
responsibility system, and
it's sort of when everything
in China starts.
Tea is one crop where women have
a comparative advantage
and even absolute advantage.
Tea is something that has to
be picked very patiently.
The most valuable leaves in
tea are the smallest ones.
So here to pick the small
leaves, you have to pick them
without bruising them.
If the leaf is bruised,
the price goes down.
The best leaf teas, like Chinese
teas, sell for $600 a
kilogram, so something of
the order of magnitude.
It's pretty expensive.
So if you actually have the best
teas, you bruise a leaf,
that costs money.
So you better have somebody
who picks with
very delicate fingers.
Whether it's true or not, I
don't know, but it's believed
in China that women are
better for picking
expensive tea leaves.
Maybe they are.
Maybe this is a story that men
made up to make them do it.
But whatever the explanation,
this is the belief.
So given that belief,
what matters is what
people believe here.
Because would imagine that
another crop, which is the
opposite, is fruits.
Fruits need someone to climb
a tree and pick them.
And again in China, the belief
is that men are better at
climbing trees--
maybe again false.
So men are better at
picking fruits.
Women are better
at picking tea.
That's starting fact.
At that's what people believe.
Let's start from there.
Now suppose parents respond
to economic incentives.
And what would you expect
happens when the
price of tea goes up?
What do you think will happen
to their daughter?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They'll treat
their daughter better.
PROFESSOR: They'll treat
They're going to feed her more,
or they're going to take
her to the hospital more
willingly, et cetera.
So you'd expect that.
And likewise, when the price
of fruits goes up, you'd
expect boys to be
treated better.
Now in fact, both price of
fruit and trees go up.
And that's a trend.
So it's hard to use a
trend to study this.
Because everything's going up.
Both tea and fruits
are going up.
So you can't distinguish
between these two.
But one thing you can do is you
can look at areas which
are suitable for tea, areas just
suitable for fruits, and
areas that were suitable
for neither.
Now you can say when tea prices
go up, do we see a
bigger change in the gender
ratio in the tea-suitable
areas relative to the others?
Or you can ask, when the price
of fruits go up, do we see a
bigger change in the gender
ratio in the fruit-favored
areas than in the areas where
neither is favored?
So we're always comparing areas
where, basically, wheat
or rice grows with tea areas
and fruit areas.
Is that clear what
we're doing?
We're asking when the price of
fruits goes up, do we see a
different trend in fruit-growing
areas, relative
to wheat-growing areas?
Is that clear why that's
a good way to
look at this question?
What are we worried about?
If we just said, well, the
price of tea is going up,
what's happening to girls?
Well, the price of tea
is going up, but it's
going up over time.
If the fraction of girls is
going down, we'll get a
negative association
out of that.
Because there are two
things happening.
One is that it's just going
down for other reasons.
The other is prices of
tea is going up for
whatever economic reasons.
And I'm going to
correlate them.
I'll find a negative
correlation.
So that's not what
we want to do.
We want to look at areas which
are suitable for tea.
That's where the price of tea
should have an effect, should
not have an effect in
areas which are not
suitable for tea.
So we're going to compare the
effect of an increase in price
of tea in girls in tea-suitable
areas versus
non-tea-suitable areas,
not compare trends.
This is basically what is called
doing a difference in
difference.
And we'll take high tea price
periods, low tea price
periods, and compare
tea-suitable areas and
non-tea-suitable areas.
You look more lost than
I would expect.
It's a very easy idea.
Somebody else want to say back
what I'm trying to say?
Who's going to volunteer to
improve on that explanation?
I'm going to [INAUDIBLE].
Somebody [INAUDIBLE]?
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Basically you're
trying to see that if this
does actually have an effect on
how parents treat children.
You'll see girls treated better
in places where tea is
the cash crop or something and
the price increases, versus
areas where tea is not
the cash crop,
but the price increases.
There shouldn't be a change in
how the girls are treated.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
So we're going to compare years
when tea prices went up
with years when tea prices
didn't go up and compare them
in areas where tea is a
plausible crop and areas where
tea cannot be grown.
So the increase in tea prices
should have no effect where
tea cannot be grown.
It will have a spurious
effect, maybe,
but no really effect.
It should have an effect
where tea can be grown.
So we're going to compare tea
possible areas with other
areas, when tea prices go up
versus when it doesn't.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How about we think
about it just like you have
you control population, where
the tea price going up
shouldn't have an effect.
And then you have your
non-control, and you just take
you data and subtract your
control from it to see you
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
exactly right.
So that's another way to
say the same thing.
Anybody else want to add
anything to that?
So let me show you
some trends.
So that's the basic fact.
So that's tea prices.
Suddenly in '79, you see stock
tea prices just skyrocketed.
That's the first fact.
Tea prices are going up.
Tea production is going up.
Second thing is that if you
look at tea versus other
crops, tea prices are going up
faster than other crops.
So other crops are like grain.
Grain is going up, but tea
is going up faster.
Oil is going up, but tea
So tea is the crop
that is going up
fastest among these crops.
Look at this one.
Here we're comparing
fruits with tea.
And fruits are going
up much faster.
Fruits with other crops, like
grain, oil, and cotton, and
again, fruits are going
up much faster.
So basically, what matters is
not the absolute price.
The relative price matters,
because it's what makes you
want to do more tea.
So tea areas are benefiting,
relative to those other areas.
So this is a complicated
graph, so
let's do this slowly.
Try to understand what's
in this graph.
So what's in this graph is areas
which grow a lot of tea.
This is the coefficient
in the regression.
So this is the effect of having
more area devoted to
tea in a particular year.
So what this is saying is that
before 1979, you see tea
prices are low.
In those years, if you look at
the fraction of males, the
fraction of males
bounces around.
But the fact that tea is sown
has essentially very close to
zero effect.
After 1979, the fact that
tea is sown has
a much bigger effect.
So this is the effect of how
much land you put into tea in
a particular year,
so year by year.
So in that year, what's
happening, in 1983, how many
boys versus girls were born
in high tea areas
relative to low tea areas?
That's always the exercise.
So think of one more percent
of land devoted to tea.
What is the effect of that
on the fraction of
boys born in 1983?
That's what that says.
So the main point to take
away is you see a
big drop after 1979.
So tea areas, the fraction of
boys born goes down right when
you think it should go down.
It is when the price
starts going up.
So that's what this is saying.
Before that, the average
is kind of at 0.15.
After that, the average
is about 0.35.
So the fraction of boys goes
down after the change.
This is what happens in
the fruit areas--
the opposite.
After '79, fruit prices
go up also a lot.
And fruit favors boys.
The ratio used to be lower.
It goes up afterwards.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are these significant
results?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so the average
is significantly different.
You're right.
Year by year, they're
not significant.
But that's because it's a
small sample of people.
But if you take the average of
these periods, the averages
are significantly different.
AUDIENCE: I'm just having
trouble understanding how so
if women are better at picking
tea leaves, the economics make
sense, but I can't see families
consciously choosing
to have more girls.
In 12 years, they'll
begin to--
PROFESSOR: Well, yes and no.
You're right with that.
But on the other hand, it also
sends a signal which reminds
them, oh well, you know.
Two things--
one, you might imagine that
the women might be more
pro-girls, plausibly.
And if you think that
women income share
goes up in the family--
AUDIENCE: They have
more stakes.
PROFESSOR: They have more say.
So that's one possible
mechanism.
The second mechanism is just
that maybe when girls' incomes
go up, they just look at it and
say, well, after all, all
the women are working
these days.
Why not have another girl?
They'll be fine.
They'll find a job as well.
I can't tell what's going
on at that level.
But it's clear that this
result is significant.
It's actually substantial.
Final set of thoughts--
suppose this goes on.
Let me back up.
What's going on?
How are they losing
all these girls?
If it's an economic mechanism,
that says that there is
incentive to lose the girls.
How are they actually
doing it?
What's going on?
Unfortunately, it's all not very
nice, what's going on.
So two things are happening.
One is basically the technology
for pre-birth
detection of gender of the
child has improved a lot.
If you do amniocentesis, which
is an expensive procedure, you
can basically very high
probability predict the gender
of the child.
The reason why rich areas are
doing the worst is precisely
because of that.
Rich areas are using
this technology.
It's an expensive technology.
You spend money to use it.
You see in like the richer parts
of India, signs up would
say, would you rather
spend basically $100
now or $10,000 later?
The idea is that you're to give
dowry for your daughter
to get her married.
And that's your cost.
And so you should really get
ready to spend, whatever, $100
now, identify her,
and then have an
abortion, rather than spend.
You see these signs up.
They're all the illegal.
Amniocentesis about eight
years ago was
made illegal in India.
It's still completely
prevalent.
And since people are willing
to try to have many babies,
they're even willing to do
it by using a much weaker
technology, which
is a sonography.
Sonography, which is a
technology that is legal, it
doesn't identify the gender of
the child all the time, but
over 25% of the time, it does.
And when it does, then you can
immediately abort the child.
So they're using technologies
to identify.
This is why this is happening
more in richer areas, because
technologies cost money.
And the poorest areas are ones
where the technology is least
used, because it's
just expensive.
So you see basically a very,
very clear correlation between
where the technology arrives
and the fraction
of boys being born.
So that's one thing
that's going on.
Second thing is going on almost
surely is a lot of
post-birth, I think, murder is
the only word you could use.
I think unfortunately there's
a lot of, I think, children
being disposed of.
There are villages which report
to have, probably
report, there's a news report I
think from like the Chinese
news agency which says that we
haven't had a girl born in our
village in the last
five years.
There's a news report of the
village chief proudly
announcing that there was no
girl born in his village in
the last five years.
So I think there is a lot of
just direct, deliberate action
going on there.
Now, there are many things
to think about here.
How do you stop it?
The government has tried.
It tried to have technologies.
There's a bunch of programs
around now, for example.
India has a number of states
where they have programs that
basically promise parents a
certain amount of money if
your girl graduates
from high school--
quite a lot of money.
So that's one way
to [INAUDIBLE]
incentives based on
girls' arrival.
But it's not clear how
well that works.
Because in some ways, it's
something that's based on 20
years later.
And you don't necessarily think
that people are that
responsive to it.
The other thing you can think
about is is there any economic
force that this, by itself, sets
off, which will then make
re-equilibrium.
So one issue that arises is
what's happening to the
marriage market?
So what do you think
will happen to the
marriage market in China?
AUDIENCE: Well, if there are
fewer women, then each one is
essentially worth more.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Dowry should go down, and bride
price should go up.
Why this hasn't happened already
in India, especially,
is that men tend to marry
women who are
younger than them.
If the population is growing,
and people marry women who are
younger than them, then even if
there are fewer girls born,
the girls are from a different
cohort, from a younger cohort.
So the population is growing, so
there's more girls around.
So that's one problem.
This force might operate,
but only if
population growth stops.
So it's going to operate more in
China where the population
growth has stopped than in India
where the population
growth is still going on.
As long as there's population
growth, you're going to see
this possibility of just going
down in the cohort chain.
So you might imagine that the
price of girls will go up, but
it won't go up if people marry
much younger women.
That's one issue.
Second issue, so in China, one
of things that people are
often puzzled about
is what's going on
with the savings rate?
The savings rate in China,
personal savings, is
historically unprecedented.
People save 30% of their
incomes, as it is compared to
the US, which used to save zero
till recently, and after
the crisis has gone up to 7%.
So personal savings rates
in China are massive.
So one puzzle people have often
been thinking about is
what's going on with that?
There's a very nice paper which
does the following.
If I look at areas which have
high gender ratios, where
women are really scarce,
are people saving
more in those areas?
Why would they save more?
Why would you save more if
you're a parent of boy?
So he particularly asked, if
you're a parent of a boy, in
China it's easy, because
people have one child.
So they're either a parent of
a boy or parent of a girl.
If you're parent of a boy in an
area where the gender ratio
is particularly bad, so very
few girls, it turns
out you save more.
Why would that be the case?
AUDIENCE: The price
of a bride.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you have
to buy your son a bride.
So people are saving more.
So basically they suggest that
people are beginning to save
more in order to buy their
child a bride.
And the way you buy it
is you don't go and
buy her in the market.
But basically women have become
very picky about not
marrying into families, which
can't afford to give their son
a separate apartment to move
into when they get married.
China has very poor
mortgage markets.
So you can't really take out
a mortgage to buy a house.
So the only you buy a house is
you borrow from your parents.
Your parents give you a gift.
So parents now, it's become a
status issue for parents to
marry this sons.
And the way you marry your son
is by buying him an apartment
when he gets married.
So if you don't have
enough wealth, you
can't buy an apartment.
And then your son can't
get married.
So this seems to be sort of one
of the facts that might
actually re-equilibriate China,
because it seems like
one thing that's going on in
China right now is this
massive increase in savings.
The problem with this method in
increasing savings is it's
a zero sum game.
There are only so many girls.
So the fact that I'm saving a
lot for my son just means my
son can have a bride, but
not anybody else.
It's not now that the number
of women go up
because they save.
So this is not really
solving the problem.
It's squeezing parents.
So if I were to save $1 more in
order to buy my son a house
so he can get married, then
somebody else is going to want
to do the same thing.
He's going to try to save even
more than me and buy a house
for his son.
So that competition is a
very kind of a negative
competition.
Everybody's getting hurt
by that competition.
So that should make parents
really rethink this strategy.
The one sign of hope I see is
this one, which is the market
forces seem to be kind
of operating to make
this problem better.
That's true in China, much less
true in India, because
India's population is growing.
So there's still this minimizing
of adjustment.
OK, so questions, comments,
before we stop?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In China, what you
see about the increase in
girls again, because parents
see that they don't have to
save money to have a girl?
PROFESSOR: So you
might see that.
You aren't seeing it yet.
But maybe once it gets clear
that your daughter gets to
live in a wonderful apartment,
et cetera, and having a son is
a huge pain because you have
to now find ways to pay for
his apartment, you might start
preferring daughters.
So maybe we'll see that.
OK, thank you.